otra vez tenemos tres objetos
desconocidos y queremos saber su valor y
lo que podemos observar es que la masa
total de estos tres objetos desconocidos
es igual a la masa de estos nueve
objetos que están de este lado que son
de un kilogramo así que de este lado
tenemos nueve kilogramos y de este lado
tenemos tres objetos desconocidos pero
de igual masa y les llamaremos x
esta vez me gustaría que abordáramos la
situación desde un punto de vista
matemático en otra ocasión ya habíamos
hecho un ejercicio y en el cual diríamos
para conservar el equilibrio qué tal si
dividimos por un tercio ambos lados y
conservaremos el equilibrio esto es la
masa total de este lado es igual a la
masa total de este lado pero tratemos de
hacerlo de una manera simbólica
esto es podremos establecer una ecuación
que relacione a estas tres masas que
llamamos equis y que su masa total sea
igual a la masa total de este lado te
daré unos segundos para ver si puedes
hacerlo
veamos que tenemos aquí de este lado
tenemos tres objetos cuya masa total es
tres veces x que lo podemos escribir
como x mas x + x
de este lado tengo 111 que son tres más
uno más 111 a ver cuántos llevó uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho y
nueve y lo que hemos hecho es una
expresión algebraica válida y podríamos
ahora verla con más cuidado y decir si
tengo 3x o sea una equis más otra equis
más otra equis entonces lo escribo como
3x y esto es igual y de este lado de acá
sumo todos los unos 11 más todos los que
sean y son 9 así que es igual a 9 y a
ver vamos a verificar uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve y
ahora podríamos preguntarnos qué podemos
hacer matemáticamente ósea observemos
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí que
podríamos hacer matemáticamente para
saber el valor de nuestra equis
misteriosa
trata de pensarlo por unos segundos
bueno y lo que hemos estado haciendo en
estos ejercicios es bueno vamos a
observar a nuestra balanza que está en
equilibrio y lo que yo haga de un lado
lo tendré que hacer del otro lado para
conservar el equilibrio y se nos podría
ocurrir bueno vamos a quitar 2x de ambos
lados y vamos a hacerlo aquí algebraica
mente pero no va a funcionar
entonces 3 x 2 x va a ser igual a 9
menos 2 x
y entonces nos quedará 3x menos 2x es
igual a una equis y de este lado nos
quedará 9
2x entonces todavía de este lado tenemos
nuestra equis misteriosa
y esto pues ya vimos no funciona pero
recordemos nuestro otro ejercicio que
pasa si tomamos un tercio de lo que está
de este lado y un tercio de lo que está
de este lado conservaríamos el
equilibrio y matemáticamente sería
equivalente a decir vamos a multiplicar
ambos lados por un tercio otra forma de
decirlo es que vamos a dividir a ambos
lados entre 3 multiplicar por un tercio
es lo mismo que dividir entre 3 si
multiplicamos ambos lados por un tercio
por ejemplo aquí visualmente multiplicar
por un tercio sólo nos va a quedar una
equis entonces multiplicamos ambos lados
por un tercio y de este lado que tengo
nueve kilogramos si multiplicó por un
tercio sólo me quedarán tres kilogramos
y también lo podríamos ver aquí si
multiplicamos por un tercio como lo
estoy indicando entonces me va a quedar
que x es igual a uno más uno más uno que
es igual a tres
hagamos las operaciones si yo multiplico
un tercio por tres me queda uno o sea
que entonces nada más tengo una equis y
de este lado si multiplico un tercio por
nueve me quedan nueve tercios que es
tres lo que es igual a tres y llegamos
al resultado